i'm a sucker for an alternate history
and when you throw space
exploration into the mix where you have
the budget to really pull it off
i mean you've definitely got my
attention for all mankind has all the
necessary ingredients to be my favorite
show
and while season 1 didn't get there i
was still curious to see what would
happen
next fast forward roughly 10 years take
us there with a montage that does a
great job of bringing us up to speed
and reminds us that the things that
happened so far have created a lot of
changes in this alternate timeline
and well i'm right there with you again
hey guys pete here
this is my breakdown for season 2
episode 1
of for all mankind on apple tv plus
as a warning this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched the
episode yet
the season 2 premiere is titled every
little thing
after the bob marley song that the
jamestown base astronauts sing together
over their radios after watching the
sunrise on the moon
before we get there we catch up with
ellen who we last saw closing out the
first season in an
interview from the exact same place at
that time she was alone after she
relieved
ed and now 10 years later she's got a
lot of company
she's still talking to larry though
making plans for when she returns
which means that she's taken deak's
advice to continue to keep her secrets
one thing that stands out from their
conversation is that it sounds like this
is
ellen's last mission building off the
momentum of the opening montage there
was a lot i'd liked about this sequence
at the base they reveal how things have
changed after the time
jump through the details that are packed
into every shot we notice how much
bigger the station is
now we see a canadian flag on one of the
astronaut suits
we see esa patches there as well and
there's more than a dozen astronauts
milling around
jamestown base is a lived-in place now
and it's easy for us to imagine how
things progressed from where they were
the last time we were there
the sunrise looks amazing and does a
great job to activate that sense of
wonder about leaving the planet earth
that pretty much everyone has had from
the time you start looking up at the
night sky
it's especially wondrous for the first
timers and the conversation where molly
is telling the dutch astronaut who's
based off the first real dutchman in
space
to stop looking at his screen and enjoy
the view
highlights one of the things that i
really love about this it shows how
going to the moon
will eventually just become another
thing we do it'll become a job for these
people
the veterans molly and ellen are already
feeling that
part of why space exploration is so
fascinating
is because we haven't done that much of
it yet we're arriving at the period in
the show's timeline where going to the
moon is just another thing we do
over 10 years because of the ongoing
space race with the soviet union things
have progressed at a rapid pace
we get a better idea of what it all
looks like when we go back to earth but
before we get into that i just want to
say that the idea of closing this
segment off on a high note with the
wonder of the sunrise
really pays off later when we return we
go back
24 hours in time and see margot wake up
in her office which is a nice call back
to her introduction in the series
and again there are plenty of details to
mark the differences from when we last
saw her
she's got photos of shuttle launches
hanging on her wall
a 20-year service award and she's got
this huge
office telling us she continued to
advance in her position
at a nasa that's moving its space
program forward at an accelerated pace
that's all good because margot is one of
my favorite characters
and after we visit her we see what's
going on with the rest of them ed
baldwin is now the chief of astronauts
he stepped into deke slayton's old role
on top of the really sweet photo he has
a molly holding the ice from the last
season on his wall
we see that there are tons of active
astronauts under his command
based on his crew chart and he's also
achieved the rank of admiral
his wife karen is now running the
outpost and they've adopted a daughter
who's already looking at college so far
we haven't really learned anything about
that
karen and ed have had some time since
the loss of their son
but we have to imagine that there's more
to learn about how they got through that
on the surface the baldwins looked to be
doing pretty good even though you have
to wonder if ed misses his time as an
astronaut
some of our other astronauts gordo and
tracy stevens on the other hand are no
longer together
gordo has let himself go he seems to be
drinking
every time he's on screen and he learned
that his
ex-wife got remarried by watching an
interview with her on television
the fact that she's on the tonight show
starring johnny carson paints a picture
where she's a pretty big celebrity
considering this was one of the most
watched shows
out there in our timeline i'll circle
back to these two when i get into
speculation about where things are going
in the season at the end of this video
the only two regular characters from
last season that we don't really get
caught up with
are danny and pam considering karen has
taken over the outpost and ellen is
still with larry
what happened to pam is an open question
we see that a lot of the other
characters are still with us
in the scenes where we move around
mission control we have a thomas payne
sighting
bill's still with us and margo's
assistant is a familiar face
and we see that there is a big tech
overhaul since the last time we seen
this place
and it's pretty impressive there's also
a noticeable increase in the military
presence
there's an office right there outside of
mission control
and i guess this is as good a time as
any to explore some of the ripple
effects that happen in this timeline
there was a lot of interesting stuff in
the opening montage
and there are a bunch of short videos
included on the watch page on apple tv
that fill in more details about the
years that have passed between
seasons some of the most important
things that jumped out to me
in relation to the show's timeline is
that ronald reagan became president in
1976
instead of 1980 and at that same time
the space treaty with the soviet
union was scrapped this means that
reagan is coming to the end of his
second term
and that there is the possibility of
militarizing things on the moon
nasa has successfully landed an unmanned
rover on mars
after several failed attempts by both
the us and the soviets
perhaps because of the continued focus
on the space race
the soviets never invaded afghanistan
and in our timeline that was a
contributing factor
in their fall they never really fully
recovered from that the us involvement
there
in operation cyclone which funded the
mujahideen
also led to the rise of terrorist
organizations in that region
and produced characters like osama bin
laden so there's some interesting ripple
effects there for how
both sides will progress over the next
few decades
and to this point nothing has happened
to slow down the space race
the us now has a fleet of nasa space
shuttles and the military
has shuttles of their own there's a next
generation shuttle called the pathfinder
already in the works and we see that
some of the technology developed for the
space program
is producing advancements in everyday
life there are electric cars now with
these cool remote controls
and three mile island never happened i
guess the thing that seems most
important for our story
is that we get the feeling that tensions
in the cold war are very high
we hear bradford mention berlin to
margot and in the video
short about 1982 we find out that there
was an incident there
at that time where a couple escaped over
the berlin wall
they were pursued by an east german tank
and killed on the other side and that
led to a situation where
the two sides exchanged fire that raised
the threat level to defcon 4
and later in the episode when the solar
storm happens
we see bradford make the recommendation
to move to deathcon
3. the solar storm is the big event of
the
episode we go back to the moon where
everything was gonna be all right
and learn that actually it's not a solar
flare event on the sun produces a
coronal mass ejection
which basically means a cloud of
radiation is moving fast away from the
sun
everything outside of earth's atmosphere
is at risk of exposure to a high dose of
radiation
on the moon all of the astronauts are
able to make it to shelter
except molly cobb and the dutch
astronaut wubbo
he crashes his rover on the way to
safety and molly has to make a decision
on whether or not to go after him
first of all this sequence looked
fantastic the regolith on the surface
lifting up
combined with the score really gave it
an intense feeling and while it seems
like going out into the radiation was a
mistake
it does track with what we know about
this character
dumb thing to do but exactly what you
would expect to see from molly
because she removed her dissimilar we
don't know for sure
how bad her exposure was but based on
what margot described we have to imagine
that she'll likely get cancer in the
future
it's not clear if she was able to save
wubbo but if she did
it's likely the last heroic move she'll
be able to make as an astronaut
and that's a good transition into where
we think things are going i think the
cold war stuff and the season 2 trailer
are certainly hinting towards a
potential armed conflict on the moon
not much in this episode to see how
that'll be set in motion though
i think ed looked pretty confident in
his role as head of astronauts but have
a suspicion we'll see him put himself on
the roster of an upcoming
mission just like deke put himself on
one back in season one
the idea of karen running her own
business seems like a way for her to
refocus
but she's such a strong character i feel
like she'll be doing more than just
upgrading the parmesan
speaking of that it feels like if the
show is jumping a decade each season
then it's set up for the conflict that
surrounds the transition
from the old school to the new
generation ed's wanting that
old cheap shaker cheese he's used to
felt like some foreshadowing to me gordo
putting on weight and blatantly getting
drunk
even ordering another scotch from the
podium while he's speaking
looks like a setup for him to try to
make a comeback it wasn't clear how much
tracy was involved with nasa at this
moment
in this episode but based on the promo
materials
it looks like she'll be heading back to
space during this season as well
margot seems like the rock still so
it'll be interesting to see what gets in
her way this season molly probably won't
die
at least not right away i have to guess
that she'll be done as an active
astronaut though
she's also a great character so let's
hope they find something for her to do
that keeps her involved with things
i thought this was a really promising
start season one had some great ideas
and some memorable events
and i never thought about not continuing
when i was watching it but it sort of
had too much going on and it just felt
weighed down and unsatisfying in a lot
of places
at the same time the space stuff all
looked great it's cool to speculate on
the idea they're putting out there
how things would change the cast is
solid all the way down
the score is top-notch and put together
they pull
off some powerful moments what's
promising about season 2
is that the world is already established
and perhaps that'll mean the end of some
of the slogginess
the beginning of the second season comes
off as a big improvement and i'm excited
to see where it goes from here
i feel like if it existed in an
alternate timeline where the show aired
on hbo in 2017
it would be a big hit and i'd probably
be doing bonus videos where we look at
every clue that we can find
hanging on the walls around mission
control so i'll probably stick with
making
videos about each episode if there's
interest and with that i think i'll
leave it there
there's a lot going on in episode 1 so
let's continue the conversation in the
comments
let me know what you think about the
show and about where you think things
are heading please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon